from a face belt to bird dropping
facials Japanese women take beauty
treatments to the next level watch your
video to get the lowdown on ten
outrageous Japanese beauty trends you
won't believe are real and if you're new
to our channel hit the red button down
below to subscribe
face bells Japanese women want to combat
the signs of aging so much so they'll
try some seriously things are gadgets
like the Koko smile line face bells koko
means smaller and the nature swing the
daily useful result in a smaller face
the belt looks like the sort of thing
Hannibal Lecter might wear this nylon
base cover is described as an anti-aging
anti-wrinkle beauty mask a claim to
tighten cheeks and facial contours
making you look younger
Hello Kitty contacts wearing colored
contact lenses isn't too strange but
wearing ones adorned with a cartoon cat
is certainly not something you see every
day
Hello Kitty contacts became a big trend
in Japan the non corrective colorful
lenses have tiny pictures of the famous
kitten drawn around them they're part of
the Japanese kawaii culture of cupid
Gwen Stefani has famously appropriated
nose straighten nerve Japanese women are
big fans of non-surgical ways to alter
their appearances so that explains why
there are so many strange Beauty gadgets
like these one has to know straightener
clip it inside your nostrils and it
pushes up the bone the maker claimed the
20 minutes daily will straighten your
nose it's name comes from the Japanese
word for nose Hana and purr stick up son
a sharp pointing up noses considered the
perfect shape rather than a rounded one
snail facial most of us wouldn't want to
see a snare when a beauty salon but
these creepy-crawlies are being used
across japan for facial treatment and
again it's all about looking younger
it's belief that the mollusk immunised
has anti-aging properties the
antioxidant hyaluronic acid and proteins
that are found in snail climb can help
remove dead skin suit inflammation and
retain moisture
f-cup cookies if you want to enhance the
size of your chest in Japan you don't
necessarily have to go under the knife
you can simply do some cookies that's
what the confectionery company that
makes F sub cookies claims by going on
this special diet and eating two cookies
a day you should notice the difference
inside they contain extracts of the
plant here re America
which contains a molecule called my
little Esther all this chemical is quite
similar to the hormone estrogen
but while estrogen does play a role in
the size of your chest there is no proof
that my rest all does to monolid surgery
there are occasions for Japanese women
believe gadgets bone cutted and plastic
surgery is required such as fluffer a
plastic commonly known as double eyelid
surgery it's one of the most popular
cosmetic procedures in Japan it makes
the eyes look bigger by changing a
hooded monolid into a western-style
double lid it's not just Western
celebrities that have popularized this
book but also Japanese pop stars
significantly had the surgery there are
even glue and tape products that
imitates look please don't try it before
committing to surgery voice trainer many
of the strange beauty trends in Japan
are understandable in the context of the
culture like the desire for a
high-pitched voice anime characters
speak in high voices and to replicate
this Japanese women can buy a beauty
voice trainer it claims to work by
opening up to voice passages and
encouraging abdominal breathing but you
have to wear a bizarre mouthpiece daily
to train your tongue and throat you're
even given a tuning fork to find the
right sound lip enhancer Kylie Jenner
lip challenge made a plump house a major
talking point for a while but in Japan
enhancing your lips with gadgets is an
ongoing trend lip enhancer tools are an
alternative to surgical procedures and
injections and the suction devices are
still a popular way to enhance your lips
without resorting to plastic surgery
brainwaves cat ears hair accessories
come in all kinds of shapes and sizes in
Japan but surely the Neko meanie
brainwave cat ears are the weirdest
conceived in Tokyo and designed in
Silicon Valley these ears respond to
brain wave function and they move to
express their emotions in cat style
they're big in Japan as a way to show
whether you're happy forward or
interested for dropping facial many of
us raise our eyebrows when Hollywood
celebrities started having facials made
from bird droppings but the fat actually
dates back to ancient times in Japan for
one 1200 years and geishas and kabuki
actors used Nightingale droppings to
lighten their skin colour it's the
protein and enzymes that are said even
else blemishes white you swim and break
down dead cells these days it's dried
under UV lights to get rid of bacteria
well that makes it fine right hmm
which Japanese beauty trend do you think
is the most outrageous let us know in
the comments below and give our video a
big thumbs up
[Music]
Oh